hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to can your pet
now when people are suggesting this game
they made the terrible mistake of saying
that this game has a horrible horrible
twist ending and that's kind of a
spoiler considering whenever I play a
cutesy game like this and people say
that it has a horrible horrible twist
ending that means that things don't end
good especially for me and what I have
to experience emotionally so without
further ado let's get on with this
torment oh boy I get to name my my
little birdy oh oh it's so adorable I'm
kind of suspicious because I have an
idea that something's not gonna go
through right okay oh they're so
adorable
oh it's so cute oh that's cute too
that's that's a little weird but I like
the Hat oh I like it too much don't I
he's a little bit sassy oh my god I like
the sassy would like I can't even
imagine what life would be like if I
didn't weren't as awesome as I am now
all the scarf
yeah the scarf I gotta love the scarf
etc why would he have a goatee
oh is that chest hair why would my birdy
have chest hair that doesn't make any
sense at all alright cool oh he's a
badass birdy he's got a scar on his
cheek because he's a badass or something
oh okay cheaper as all his clothing
how you doing cheaper oh I get to feed
you oh you ate the whole bag and
everything I'm sure that's really
nutritious for you and you're gonna like
that you seemed happy for little fits
and bursts at a time the rest are just
kind of in a malaise about life
dude if you'd seen the things that I've
seen you live the life that I lived you
wouldn't be so happy either and if you
know about the horrible to a-standing
you know the things don't go right oh
okay I need to feed more because there's
a feed ohmmeter to judge when my birdie
little jeepers is gonna be full for
whatever reason I have ideas about
what's gonna happen but I do
no it's gonna happen I don't know why oh
that's adorable
oh he doesn't like it Oh little cheaper
does like it I can't tell if you like it
or not
little cheaper do you want to get washed
come on you need to be clean for
whatever happens next
no he's not fully cleaned yet and I
gotta wash him off I gotta wash it off
I'm a cheaper I'm a cheaper dammit I
really did think that something was
gonna happen by now did you play with
the ball did you play with the ball oh
oh oh so huge
Oh jeepers you're so cute why are you so
cute what's gonna happen I don't know
what's gonna happen it's eating me up
inside like that you son of a god
damn it oh you're so evil why would you
do that it's a pun it's a horrible
horrible fun I thought I'd prepared
myself
that's that sadistic and sad I was
growing attached to cheaper which I'm
sure is a whole point of this game so
there you go that's can your pet I hope
you all enjoyed that whoever suggested
that game you you you you you you you're
good
horrible and lovely so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
have a because oh my goodness so thank
you everybody so much check out the
other awesome games that I played that
don't have to extending or maybe they do
I won't confess boiler so thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
got pineapples pineapples ratings from
snake heaven Thank You snake God